[музика]
Вітаю і Ласкаво просимо на програму У
фокусі Європа раді що ви приєдналися до
нас сьогоднішню програму Ми розпочинаємо
з невеликої історії з Португалії вона не
лише про те як отримати максимум від
свого життя але що більш важливо про те
як мати сміливість спробувати щось нове
і складне Ця історія відбувається на
Атлантичному узбережжі Португалії
славнозвісний рай для серфінгістів
особливо це проявляється Взимку коли
величезні хвилі приваблюють спортсменів
з усього світу
Якщо ви хочете познайомитися з одним із
найсміливіших серверів то я хотів би
представити вам Марію
сусуда дівчина з радістю занурюється з
головою хвилі біля Португалії хоча долає
надзвичайно перешкоду щоб стати на дошку
адже вона страждає на захворювання
нервової системи але на пляжі каркаолуш
вона разом з іншими членами своєї групи
серфінгістів знає що не розмір хвилі має
найбільше значення а саме відчуття які
отримуєш коли їдеш на ній
[музика]
серфінг у Португалії більше ніж спорт це
спосіб життя
хвиля Атлантики приваблюють серферів з
усього світу на пляж каркавелуш поблизу
Лісабона
і 14-річна Марія суса теж тут для неї
стрибати у хвилі це другий я попри
спастичну параплегію
сти а Це доволі складно Якщо ти не
займався цим раніше
але якщо роками цим займався То ніяких
проблем не буде
Кая асіс має синдром дауна та
пошкодження мозку через те що при
народженні він не отримував достатньої
кількості кисню але зараз йому 47 і його
не зупинити Кая та Марія члени сюрф Едіт
або серфозалежні асоціація адаптованого
серфінгу
я став постійним учасником відтоді як
вперше познайомився з групою
перед тим як зайти у воду серфінгісти та
їхні помічники роблять розминку
України
тренерка Тереза абрасус знає у чому
основна суть серфінгу
у тому щоб отримувати задоволення бути
тут і зараз і робити щось для свого тіла
та розуму усі люблять серфінг усі
люблять бути на пляжі люблять
спілкуватися
це терапія не лише для серверів а для
волонтерів та їхніх родин
і ось час настав Кая та його друзі
хочуть нарешті покататися на хвилях
[музика]
вони у своїй стихії тут на дошці для
серфінгу вони краще відчувають на що
насправді здатні
[музика]
це свобода ти у воді просто кричиш від
того який ти щасливий і відчуваєш повну
свободу робити це адже ти у відкритому
морі
[музика]
їхня тренер катереза також постійно
переживає щось нове разом із групою
я багато чому навчилася від людей з
інвалідністю вони допомогли мені
замислитись над своїм життям чому я
скаржився на дрібниці я повинна бути
вдячною за те що може робити багато чого
самостійно і займатися серфінгом
але її робота - це ще й велика
відповідальність і не завжди все йде
гладко альфонсо щойно змило з дошки усі
підключаються в тому числі і Кая Він
хоче бути взірцем для людей з
інвалідністю
Я хочу допомагати інший вчитися кататися
на серфі
навіть незважаючи на свої вади
через дві години Марія втомилася але
вона вже з нетерпінням чекає наступного
тренування на пляжі каркавелос
Я мрію навчитися кататися на серфі ще
краще але мені подобається і так як є
Головне щоб у мене все виходило Головне
що я хочу не зупинятися на досягнутому
[музика]
Кая Марія та інші кажуть що практично
кожен може займатися серфінгом
а в Португалії серфінг - це спосіб життя
[музика]
вони не хочуть вмирати за Путіним
Олексій молоді росіяни і вони проти
війни в Україні через цей покинули свою
країну
Вони дуже боялися що їх використати як
гарматне м'ясо на фронті і тому втекли
від Російської мобілізації до сусідньої
країни до Грузії
там Вони намагаються будувати нове життя
в столиці Тбілісі як і десятки тисяч
інших росіян
але Наразі це не дуже легко багато
грузинів виступають проти нещодавнього
напливу росіян головним чином через
Гірке минуле з недружнім сусідом
Тбілісі столиця Грузії
війна Росії проти України змінила
південно-кавказьку націю
прояви народного спротиву путінський
агресії повсюди зараз серед них молоді
люди які виїхали з Росії боєчись що їх
змусять брати участь у війні яку їхня
країна веде проти України
дехто називає мене зрадником
не знаю Я вважаю що ті хто йде на війну
зраджують і Батьківщину і людяність і
людство А я кого зраджую Путіна
так зраджую а тепер от втік
[музика]
Я проти цієї війни у цьому конфлікті я
за Україну і кажу про це чесно прямо і
відкрито а тут відправляють мене за ці
путінські амбіції сумнозвісний русский
мир який мені геть не близький що
вмирати за нього
Мене звуть Олександр я з Петербурга
приїхав у Тбілісі Мені 26 років
Олександр працював токарем у
санкт-петербурзі коли Росія вторглася в
Україну в лютому він приєднався до акції
протесту і був затриманий коли
наприкінці вересня Путін віддав наказ
про мобілізацію Він вирішив що настав
час їхати зібрав свої речі і втік
пітусовка Це мій велосипед на якому я
переходив російсько-грузинський кордон
він провів на кордоні два дні били
страшного було страшнувато що не
випустять
на шляху поки ми рухались було багато
поліцейських які постійно зупиняли людей
постійно дивилися документи лякали що
можуть повістку видати але мені було все
одно я просто рухався до мети
перейшли кордон схід сонця гори Свобода
після приїзду у Тбілісі Олександру
пощастило це дядько Енріке він нас
прихистив одяг на мені практично весь
теж від дядька Енріке
Ну мені їх шкода Ну не хочуть вони
воювати не хочуть вбиратися Путіна не
було б мобілізації він би не приїхав
вони не знали що прийде час що вони
розбіжуться як пацюки з корабля що тоне
вони Всі розумні всі хороші а хто там
залишається Ну я і не знаю
на відміну від країн Балтії та Фінляндії
Грузія не закрила свої кордони для
росіян багато грозинів ставляться до
цього скептично А якщо до країни без
перешкодно потраплять прихильники Путіна
або навіть шпигуни я бачу таку велику
різку зміну в кількості людей я постійно
чую російську мову з відусіль і це дуже
неприємно Ми пройшли також війну як і
Україна спочатку була Абхазія Потім був
2008 рік коли вони вторглися удві
частини Грузії Я просто не можу бути
теплою і великодушною по відношенню до
цих людей по-перше коли вони підходять
до тебе спілкуватися вони починають
розмовляти з тобою російською мовою
брате це Грузія Чому ми повинні говорити
з вами російською ми ж можемо розмовляти
англійською хіба ні це така непова і це
так грубо з їхнього боку
звісно У мене є розуміння що я тут гість
що моя країна винна і перед грузією теж
[музика]
І що Для когось це може бути певним
тригром можливо якось Косино мене
подивитися
всі ставилися по-людськи до мене
Мене звуть Алексей мені 32 роки Я з
міста Чебоксари чувакська республіка
Алексей до 2016 року був професійним
військовим як досвідчений артилерист він
був потрібен на передовій Я був
здивований що повістка не прийшла мені
одразу Вона прийшла коли я вже був тут
мені сестра надіслала фото в телеграм
я був щасливим запізнилися
він вже кілька тижнів знаходиться в
Грузії намагається освоїтись там
якнайкраще після років служби у війську
Олексій не хотів більше мати нічого
спільного з російською армією йому
більше до вподоби життя заробітчанина
він абсолютно не розуміє співвітчизників
які не чинять опір мобілізації
Мені кажеться до конца не представтесь
Мені здається вони не до кінця розуміють
що їх там чекає що вони будуть там як
худоба
іржаві автомати п'янь тобіки
на себе сліз не подивишся
якби мене все ж таки відправили на фронт
то вихід був тільки один обговорити
умови здачу полон і не йти на обмін
[музика]
Почему чому мама каже що навіть вона
пішла в за батьківщину
громадянина наши НАТО хоче завоювати
Америка я сказав що це все повна брехня
Це все просто з телевізора його мати
хотіла щоб він воював він почувається
безпечно висловлюючи свої політичні
погляди в Грузії Олексій хоче
повернутися до Росії але тільки після
закінчення війни і зміни влади
[музика]
у Тбілісі у Олександра з'явилося багато
друзів він все ще живе в Енріке і шукає
роботу незабаром до нього приєднаються
його дівчина також Тбілісі Олексій шукає
нове житло і заробляє на життя
підробітками його мати вже змирилася з
його рішенням покинути Росію вони
розмовляють але не про війну
російська війна в Україні не просто
спровокувала енергетичну кризу в Європі
вона призвела до того що у звичайних
європейців просто стало менше грошей
кишенях через інфляцію особливо сильно
постраждали жителі Естонії яку повинен
спроможність яких у цій балтійській
країні впала на рекордні 20%
для таких як сім'я марітін це стало
місяцями тихих страждань економії
але навіть якщо доводиться вимикати
опалення через скасовувати недільне
барбекю багато людей готові йти на ці
жертви Цієї зими із солідарності з
Україною
приготування омлету - це спільне
задоволення для всієї родини мар'єтін
батько Арон та донька Ельвіра
спостерігають як чотирирічний Теодор
приправляє яйця
раніше сім'я також любила замовляти щось
на обід але зараз їхні гаманці Стали
тугішими вони помічають це навіть коли
готують звичайний омлет
на омлет для сім'ї йде пачка з 10 яєць
а ціна на них значно зросла
в Естонії де люди заробляють набагато
менше ніж у Німеччині ціни зросли у 4
рази
Мар'я працює на півставки в університеті
у Талліні де заробляє 850 євро на місяць
її чоловік Арон фотограф восени він
підвищив ціни на свої послуги щоб
зводити кінці з кінцями
гроші буквально танули на очах ти
працюєш але нічого не залишається тому
довелося підвищити ціну
особливо з’їдають бюджет рахунки за
електроенергію та опалення Арон
спостерігає в додатку як тарифи
зростають і щомісяця обходяться йому все
дорожче
залежно від договору держава допомагає
на кілька центів за кіловат-годину але
не більше однак родина залишається
спокійною
повставати зараз проти держави чи
конкретних компаній було б неправильно
ці проблеми комплексні
путінський режим в Росії спричинив цю
енергетичну кризу а застосовуючи
енергетику як зброю
зима прийшла в столицю Естонії італіїн
попереду темні холодні місяці
у супермаркетах вибір як ніколи широкий
але багато з цих товарів Естонія змушена
імпортувати зростання цін все відчутніше
інфляція що досягла рекордного рівня у
понад 20% б'є по всіх
Але не всі можуть впоратися із цим
самотужки
[музика]
держава допомагає тисячам українських
біженців та багатьом малозабезпеченим
громадянам
за останні місяці кількість звернень
зросла учетверо
Таня ми не бачили з часів фінансової
кризи 2008 року
останні дані показують що особливо
вразливі люди похилого віку та
пенсіонери
журналістика більшість самотніх
пенсіонерів живуть у відносній бідності
ті хто отримує мізерну пенсію часто
приходять сюди до таллінської асоціації
самодопомоги літнім людям щодня в обідню
перерву заклад повністю заповнений
поїсти тут можна за кілька центів
пізніше за рукоділлям у сусідній кімнаті
Вони часто говорять про своє становище
жінки як наприклад лайки колись
працювали на Текстильній фабриці
сьогодні їм доводиться якось
викручуватися
Я завжди шукаю акційні пропозиції Якби
мені довелося платити повну ціну я б не
прожила
я відправила українцям шапки і шарфи
в Естонії ми знаємо як там страшно
це і наша війна теж
але ми краще потерпимо інфляцію ніж
бомби
багато хто в Естонії поділяється
настроєм мало хто протестує проти уряду
хоч і не всі можуть розраховувати на
допомогу
пенсіонери отримали одноразову субсидію
а сім отримують більше допомоги на дітей
решті треба Просто якось давати собі
раду каже міністр від про бізнесової
партії реформ
естонці стійкі Навіть зараз переважна
більшість просто намагається впоратися з
ситуацією
А ми як держава намагаємось допомогти
додаткова підтримка для дітей трохи
допомагає і сім'ї марітін але справжньо
полегшення вони відчувають лише тоді
коли вимикають опалення взимку
А зараз ми просто одягаємо вовняні
светри і вовняні шкарпетки
ми можемо це зробити треба думати про
інших Коли ти думаєш про те як живеться
людям в Україні ти не можеш скаржитися
на 19 градусів у квартирі
завдяки своїй стійкості Вони можливо вже
пройшли через найважче
прогнози оптимістичні інфляція має
сповільнитися у найближчі місяці
незважаючи на те що в деяких
європейських країнах знову
спостерігається невеликий збільшення
кількості хворих на коронавірус багато
людей ставляться до пандемії досить
спокійно як наприклад у страсбурзі це у
Франції де життя майже повернулися до
нормального ритму після всіх локдаунів
та обмежень контактів але деякі з цих
правил мали досить небажаний побічний
ефект якщо ви думаєте що ця історія про
збільшення ваги то в певному сенсі Ви
праві але це не про французів які не
брали заві кілограмів що сталося з
багатьма з нас під час карантину це про
певних тварин які набрали ваги і вони
розмножуються до того ж масово
у Франції розвелося багато щурів під час
пандемії коронавірусу вони розподілилися
майже у всіх великих містах
дезінсектор і щуролов тєрі бодон працює
безперервно він ходить Від підвалу до
підвалу розкладаючи щурячого труту
якщо у вас слабкі нерви Ця робота не для
вас у будь-який момент на тебе може
вискочити Щур
і щурів стало набагато більше ніж до
карантину щуролови не могли покидати
своїх домівок а гризуни вільно
розмножувалися
щури народжують по 8-10 малят кожні
два-три місяці
за два роки це більше 100 тисяч щуряд це
нескінченна боротьба
у мальовничому елізавському мегаполісі
страсбурзі щури також отримали
оптимальні умови завдяки пандемії
їхня чисельність різко зросла і вони
повсюди
це справжня
доволі чистий Але шкода що мешканці не
дуже уважні до цього
щорів треба знищити я їх ненавиджу Я їх
боюся
проблема особливого гостра тут у бідних
кварталах страсбурга
бачите їх там
вони скрізь
Коли ви йдете по подвір’ї ви бачите їх
на кожному кроці
і це в європейській столиці страсбурзі
столиці прав людини це ганьба
так не може тривати далі
не можна щоб люди жили серед пацюків і
тарганів
живе у цьому районі уже 30 років
він розлючений на міську владу
люди тут змушені жити серед щурів
ці тварини їдять дроти в машинах і вже
навіть кусали людей а в міській раді
обговорюють чи справді що решкідливі чи
все ж їм місце в нашій екосистемі ці
люди живуть на іншій планеті або вони
Божевільні або одне з двох
будгата відстоює свою позицію знімаючи
щурів як тут на автомобільному двигуні і
публікує відео в інтернеті
його популярність у соціальних мережах
спонукає Страсбург до дій
член міськради Бенджамін суле не хоче
винищувати щурів а навпаки хоче змусити
їх залишитися під землею почавши з цього
смітника
там були дірки через які Щури пролазили
ми встановили цю решітку і тепер вони не
можуть вилізти
але як скаржиться багато мешканців від
щурів це не рятує
у міськраді стверджують що проблема
пов'язана з побутом бо французи під час
карантину більше готували вдома
це ефект коронавірусу люди набагато
більше готували вдома і викидали більше
залишків їжі
ресторани були закриті це сприяло
розмноженню щурів
і це стосується всієї країни сьогодні
підраховано що на кожного французького
містянина припадає майже два Щури
і зараз вони мають навіть політичний
лобі
міськрада страсбурга розділилася на
групи за і проти щурів
тварини не можуть просто так повернутися
до життя в дикій природі
їм нікуди йти
Основне питання в тому як допомогти
людям а не в тому як зробити так щоб
щури почувалися комфортніше
такої ж думки і дезінсектор Terry bodon
нещодавно він пройшов тренінг з більш
ефективних методів боротьби з пацюками
вчора будуть завжди Тут стільки будинків
соціальних житлових масивів Ми завжди
будемо потрібні
А зараз будон і його колеги застосовують
свої нові знання на практиці тож
французьких щурів можуть чекати нелегкі
часи
у нашій останній історії на сьогодні
хотів би познайомити вас з мо він
біженець із судану який почав нове життя
в Англії і зараз він настільки відомо що
його впізнають на вулицях
зірка соціальних мереж І багато хто
захоплюється ним це тому що займаючись
своїми ремесло він став прикладом
милосердя і доброти до незнайомців
особливо напередодні Різдва
приємно нагадування для всіх на про
необхідність піклуватися про нужденних у
цей святковий період А на сьогодні це
все від імені всієї нашої команди У
фокусі Європи Дякуємо що приєдналося до
нас будьте здорові і до зустрічі в
наступному випуску
українською мовою озвучено центром Меді
ініціатив Київ 2022 рік